TODD:  WELCOME BACK.
THE WIDEN ADMINISTRATION’S
HANDLING OF THE BORDER PROMPTING
BACKLASH FROM REPUBLICAN
LAWMAKERS ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
JILLIAN:  OUR NEXT GUEST, A
CONGRESSWOMAN FROM MICHIGAN,
JUST RETURNED FROM A TRIP TO
WITNESS THE DANGERS OF THE
MIGRANT SURGE FIRSTHAND AND IS
CALLING ON THE PRESIDENT TO PUT
AMERICANS FIRST.
HERE TO BREAK DOWN WHAT SHE SAW
IS MICHIGAN CONGRESSWOMAN LISA
MCCLAIN.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE THIS
MORNING.
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
JILLIAN:  OF COURSE.
YOU SAID IT WAS ACTUALLY WORSE
THAN YOU EXPECTED IT TO BE.
CAN YOU EXPLAIN TO US WHAT YOU
SAW?
>> YEAH.
AS A MOTHER, FIRST AND FOREMOST,
WHOYOU WANT THE BEST FOR YOUR KI
AND WHAT’S HAPPENING TO THESE
FAMILIES IS AN ORGANIZED FORM OF
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION THAT I WOULD
ARGUE IS MODERN DAY SLAVERY.
THE ONLY PEOPLE THAT ARE MAKING
OUT IN THIS SITUATION ARE THE
DRUG TRAFFICKERS, THE CARTELS,
AND THE PEOPLE THAT TRAFFIC
THESE FAMILIES OVER.
IT IS THE WORST -- IT’S WORSE
THAN I THOUGHT.
I WOULD SUGGEST THAT BEFORE YOU
HAVE AN OPINION, COME DOWN FROM
YOUR IVORY TOWER AND ACTUALLY GO
TO THE BORDER AND SEE FOR
YOURSELF WHAT IS HAPPENING.
IT WAS HORRIBLE.
TODD:  CONGRESSWOMAN, HOW VITAL
IS IT THAT EVERY AMERICAN
REALIZE THAT, YES, YOU MAY NOT
LIVE IN A BORDER STATE, YOU MAY
NOT LIVE AT THAT TIME THE BORDER
BUT THIS CRISIS IS COMING TO
YOUR COMMUNITY IN SOME WAY,
SHAPE OR FORM, WHETHER YOU LIKE
IT OR NOT.
>> WELL, IT’S COMING TO YOUR
COMMUNITY IN TWO-FOLD.
ONE, I LIVE IN MICHIGAN.
SO THEY DO NOT HAVE THE
FACILITIES TO HOUSE THESE
UNDERAGE ILLEGAL MIGRANT
CHILDREN.
WHAT THEY’RE DOING IS THEY’RE
BUSSING THEM AND FLYING THEM UP
TO MY CITY, HERE IN ALBION,
MICHIGAN, NUMBER ONE.
NUMBER TWO, WHERE IT’S COMING TO
A CITY NEAR YOU, IS BECAUSE THE
BORDER PATROL AGENTS ARE
SPENDING SO MUCH TIME DEALING
WITH ALL OF THESE FAMILIES THAT
ARE CROSSING ILLEGALLY, THEY
HAVE NO TIME TO PROTECT THE
BORDER.
WHAT DO YOU THINK IS COMING IN?
FENTANYL, COCAINE, WHAT HEROIN,
ASSURE YOU THAT’S COMING TO A
CITY NEAR YOU.
JILLIAN:  APPROXIMATELY $3
BILLION IN GOVERNMENT CONTRACTS
AWARDED BY THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION TO HOUSE MY
GRANTS.
IF YOU -- MIGRANTS.
IF YOU COULD HAVE A CONVERSATION
WITH THE PRESIDENT AND VICE
PRESIDENT ON THAT SITUATION,
WHAT WOULD YOU SAY TO THEM?
>> NUMBER ONE, GET DOWN TO THE
BORDER.
YOU CAN’T FIX A PROBLEM UNLESS
YOU THINK WE HAVE ONE AND A I AM
TELLING YOU, MR. PRESIDENT, WE
HAVE A CRISIS AT THE BORDER.
ALL YOU HAVE TO DO IS GO DOWN
THERE AND YOU WILL SEE
FIRSTHAND.
NUMBER TWO, I’M FOR LEGAL --
LEGAL IMMIGRATION.
BUT WHAT’S HAPPENING AT THE
BORDER, THAT IS NOWHERE CLOSE TO
LEGAL IMMIGRATION.
AND WHAT WE’RE DOING TO THESE
FAMILIES, WE’RE RECYCLING THE
CHILDREN SO THE CHILDREN COME
OVER, THEN THE CARTELS TAKE
THEM, SEND THEM BACK TO MEXICO
TO LET THEM GET ABUSED AND RAPED
WITH ANOTHER FAMILY ON THE WAY
OVER.
THAT’S HORRIBLE.
JILLIAN:  AWFUL.
TODD:  WHAT WE’RE DOING TO THESE
KIDS IS UNCONSCIONABLE.
>> IT IS.
TODD:  YOUR COLLEAGUES IN THE
HOUSE, THE REPUBLICANS IN FACT
DEMANDING ANSWERS FROM THE CHIEF
OF TIKTOK OVER CARTELS USING THE
APP TO ORGANIZE, SMUGGLE, ALL
THAT STUFF.
HERE’S PART OF THE LETTER, IT
APPEARS THAT CARTEL MEMBERS ARE
GLORIFYING ILLEGAL BEHAVIOR TO
RECRUIT NEW MEMBERS.
THE PROLIFERATION IS OCCURRING
ON SUCH A LARGE SCALE THAT IT’S
BEING REFERRED TO AS CARTEL
TIKTOK CULTURE.
HOW COME SOCIAL MEDIA IS SO
QUICK TO BAN CONSERVATIVE
VIEWPOINTS, YET IT TAKES A
LETTER FROM CONGRESS TO EVEN
START THE CONVERSATION ON WHAT
AMOUNTS TO ILLEGAL SMUGGLING VIA
AN APP?
>> BECAUSE WE ARE SO WORRIED
ABOUT THE OPTICS THAT WE’RE NOT
DEALING WITH THE ISSUES.
WE ARE CLEARLY SYMBOLISM OVER
SUBSTANCE FROM THIS
ADMINISTRATION AND AS A PARENT,
THAT SHOULD ENRAGE YOU.
AS AN AMERICAN CITIZEN, THAT
SHOULD ENRAGE YOU.
I MEAN, COME ON.
THEY ARE TAKING OUR DATA,
SELLING OUR DATA.
THEN THEY ARE USING TIKTOK TO
EXPLOIT OUR CHILDREN.
OUR CHILDREN.
JILLIAN:  DEVASTATING.
WELL, CONGRESSWOMAN MCCLAIN,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR JOINING
US.
I SEE YOU GOT THE PALE YELLOW
BLAZER MEMO.
TODD DID NOT.
TODD:  I DID NOT.
PLEASE INCLUDE ME ON THAT CHAIN.
JILLIAN:  THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR JOINING US.